in August of 2018 I released a video
discussing the characters Vegeta and
Goku asking you the audience to decide
which of the two you identify with more
and who you might want to be if given
the choice by an incredibly wide margin
Vegeta was the character chosen so I
asked on Twitter why don't people like
Goku and these were the most common
talking points number one he's
one-dimensional number two he's childish
and number three because of his
character he can be seen as predictable
and boring and while I don't agree at
all with his character being boring or
one-dimensional check out my last video
I can 100% gone bored with the notion
that he's not a relatable character
insofar as it pertained to some large
aspects of his persona and morals which
is why we have the antihero
enter the cheetah
flawed unapologetic when it comes to
getting the job done and oh so relatable
since his debut of the late 80s Vegeta
has become a globally recognized
character and is a favorite for many in
the series but how does one write and
antihero character and how did Akira
Toriyama make a character like Vegeta
that resonated with so many people well
let's take a look
what makes an antihero a lot of the time
nowadays many script writers both for TV
and film create antihero characters that
are just for lack of a better term
one-dimensional Basterds and while a
certain age is part of it it is on a
fundamental level not what makes an
antihero
an antihero anti heroes are great guys
who turned bad for sympathetic reasons
right for sympathetic reasons Michael
Corleone II becomes a horrible man why
he's saving his family right Tony
Soprano is a horrible guy but we like
him why because he wants to save his
family when writing the antihero
character it is important to understand
what makes an antihero and what does not
make an antihero
for example the antihero of the story is
not the villain of the story which means
that Vegeta has not always been the
antihero character he became one when he
was first introduced during the Saiyan
arc of Dragon Ball Z his actions were
seemingly irredeemable it wasn't until
after the fight with Goku did we notice
another side to Vegeta typically in a
movie the antihero is such from the
beginning a central character that lacks
conventional heroic attributes while
they may fight bravely they might not be
selfless and if they are strong they
might not be merciful usually acting
heroically are doing heroic stuff
because it's in their own self-interest
or they might believe as their
responsibility among other ideals they
hold to be true what are the most
important facets of storytelling that
made Vegeta's eventual antihero turns so
compelling was his slow shift from the
villain role to neutral and eventually
to the good and that right there is
something that set Vegeta apart from
many of the anti heroes of the 80s time
period he developed boy you might be
asking at this point is if Vegeta wasn't
always the antihero how do they change
him into one so the great secret Ana
here
to make the villains and the people
around them worse and less likeable than
the hero themselves so Tony Soprano's
mom is the most miserable horrible human
being
ever conceived on television but so we
love Tony because his mom is just so
awful and we think God poor god no
wonder he turned into a murdering
psychopath the sympathetic character if
there's one surefire way to make your
antihero shine it's by writing a story
where he has to overcome an even more
despicable evil once Vegeta suffered the
defeat at the hands of Goku we are
greeted by this scene while not taking
anything to heart we got our first
indication that Vegeta might not be the
top dog and at one point perhaps
suffered ridicule at the hands of his
superiors that's relatable and that
creeping sense of sympathy is made even
more palpable with the introduction of
Frieza
as I said before an antihero can be
ruthless and merciless he does not need
to be selfless and merciful but the
audience does need to sympathize with
him on some level and he needs to be
juxtaposed to a more severe evil in the
case of Vegeta despite being a seemingly
irredeemable character when he was first
introduced slowly the story fed us more
and more information about why he is the
way he is how his allies see him how his
superiors betrayed him and what life
growing up in subjugation must have been
like
[Music]
the key to connecting an anti-hero to
the audience is sympathy their actions
and moral standing might be questionable
but when the audience can empathize with
the character then they are also able to
accept and understand why he is the way
he is on top of that it frees up space
for us to see his redemption er or good
sight more clearly the beginning of this
for Vegeta was unknown ik his escapades
ducky and weaving around freezes men as
he tried to get the dragonballs for
himself was always a joy to watch and it
was so because we knew he was the lesser
of two evils and had a common enemy with
our heroes which led to this
[Music]
that might be a fun moment to look back
on but it was also the very first time
Vegeta's actions coincided with what the
main cast of good guys wanted and from
that moment on Vegeta had cemented
himself as an antihero
fighting albeit poor growingly alongside
the rest of the Earth's fighters even
going so far as to heal Goku before the
impending Frieza attack and all of that
played into another aspect of Vegeta
that made his antihero so successful and
more importantly compelling he is an
active character that drives the story
forward if you have a full character
that's real that you've created and then
you put something in front of them in a
way they will begin to write the movie
because you know how they're gonna react
to whatever you put in front of them
because they're now these dimensional
characters as opposed to let's have this
happen let's have this happen they said
this happened and we'll just make sure
that they do these things that I've
gained and I think that's what creates a
feeling of artifice or you've seen it
all before or boring I think Vegeta is a
compelling character because instead of
waiting for the story to happen to him
which would be a reactive thing to do
Vegeta the character takes action and
tries to manipulate the odds to his
favor because of this character trait
Vegeta has caused many many terrible
things to happen as well as the good
that I mentioned before regardless
because his character has an active
approach to the story we the audience
find him extremely interesting to watch
because he is the one that moves the
plot forward and that is immensely
compelling opposites attract interest
whenever things get stale in a medium
the antihero has frequently been the
tool a new generation of artists used to
escape the traps the mediums fallen into
and it makes sense in a really
reductionist way the antihero is simply
a rebellion against whatever the medium
has established as a norm the
introduction of characters like piccolo
and Vegeta was a rebellion against what
had become the norm
Dragonball was the story of Goku until
he became a man but the story of Goku as
a man needed to be different and so
Akira Toriyama renamed this section of
the series onward Dragon Ball Z to
reflect that it was coming to an end and
to represent a change in the direction
this series was taking and
reflect that change the main character
introduced during the initial arc of Z
was Vegeta this is a phenomenon that is
observed in every single instance a
certain genre gains a large amount of
notoriety for a long period of time
crime dramas were once all the rage and
so to subvert the trope of having the
good guy protagonist to the genre the
antihero Walter White was created a
sympathetic complicated character that
was doing the wrong thing for all the
right reasons
superhero films now thrive in the
box-office and so it became the perfect
time to have a movie like Deadpool
become a worldwide success now I am by
no means saying that Deadpool was
successful is just because of its
subversion of our expectations the film
was also very well written and shot
however what I am saying is that when a
certain genre becomes stale is
inevitably gives rise to an antihero in
that genre the show turns on R was
inundated with good boys like Goku and
so added an edge into the mix as a main
character giving rise to a whole new
kind of shown in antihero whether or not
Vegeta was the first in manga doesn't
really matter he is the one that has
stood the test of time as the example
don't believe me how many times have you
heard someone say that so and so is the
Vegeta
of that show it might be due to their
moral complexity or even their choices
mirroring our own but anti-heroes for
one reason or another are intensely
interested we earnestly root for their
Redemption and salivate at the thought
of them paying for their mistakes Vegeta
is an antihero that has stood the test
of time when faced with moral Paragons
like Gohan and krillen or morally grey
characters like son Goku we the audience
understand and sympathize with the
choices and actions of a great antihero
like Vegeta speaking on the rise of the
antihero H Erik bender wrote anti-heroes
liberate us they reject social
constraints and expectations imposed
upon us anti-heroes give our grievances
a voice they make us feel like something
right is being done even if it's legally
wrong anti-heroes do things were afraid
to do they are who they are and they do
as they want without apology and I gotta
say for 30 minutes every week watching
Dragon Ball Z we lived vicariously
through him without apology
thank you so much for watching
[Music]
you